يحصل مطعم اللبان على بعض
التألق الكبير ، وكل ذلك بفضل هذا
الفيديو المنشور على tick tock ،
هذا أحد أفضل
الأجنحة التي حصلت عليها على الإطلاق.
افتتح ستيل ستيل متجره منذ أربعة أشهر
ويقول إن العمل لم يكن
بداية جيدة تمامًا ، لكن في ليلة الإثنين ،
كانت هناك معجزة أتى بها هذا الرجل ولم أكن
أعرف من هو
وأحب أن أسأل زبائني أنك تعرف
أين أنت  ما تفعله
وقال بهدوء إنني ناقد طعام يقول فرانك
الكثير منه حتى بعد ساعات قليلة عندما
أصبح العمل مشغولاً ، هاتفنا لم
يتوقف عن الرنين ، لقد بعت المزيد من أجنحة الليمون والفلفل
في اليومين الماضيين.
في الأشهر الأربعة الماضية ،
صنعت المزيد من حبات الثوم بالأمس لدرجة أنني
جعلت
تقييم Lee على Tick Tock قد جذب
انتباه الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
ويعكس قوة
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي يكتبها شخص واحد ، وآمل أن
يحصل فرانك على كل الأعمال  إنه يستحق
قولًا آخر لا أعرف لماذا
جعلني هذا عاطفيًا ، أريد أن أقابل
فرانك الآن وأدعمه ، ويقرأ هذا التعليق
أتمنى لو كنت في فيجاس فرانك ، طعامك
يبدو ناريًا ، لدي أشخاص قادمون من ولاية
أيوا أشخاص من كاليفورنيا لدي
عائلة  تعال من بحيرة هافاسو ، كان لدي
أشخاص نزلوا من ولاية يوتا ،
تمت مشاهدة الفيديو الآن أكثر من 18 مليون
مرة وأعجب به أكثر من 4 ملايين
شخص لأن فرانك ، كل ذلك لا يزال
موجودًا ، هل كنت
تتوقع ما كنت عليه صباح الاثنين
سأستيقظ في اليوم التالي
وما كانت عليه هذه الساعات الـ 72 الماضية كانت
ساحقة ، لقد
كان هذا المطعم
حلمي لمدة
30 عامًا
30 عامًا في Las Vegas Alyssa
bethancourt
ABC 13.